Recently you discussed that via your protocols or other methods, tumor growth can be
stopped and therefore no longer fits the definition of cancer.
You also mentioned that unless there's a pressing medical reason a person can often just
live with no longer cancer as tumor.
I was wondering if you could address how once the tumor no longer fits the definition of
cancer, one can still reduce the size of the tumor or completely eliminate the tumor
through non-surgical methods.
Any particular successful case studies that is colon cancer that you are liberty to discuss
will be helpful too.
So yes, I said that if a cancer stops growing, so let's say you have a mass in your colon,
it's three centimeters round, let's say, and then three months later, it's 4.5 centimeters
round and let's say you start chemo therapy and then you measure it again three months
later and it's 4.5 centimeters round.
Well, three months it didn't grow at all, that's a good thing, right, and you do chemo
and you're still doing chemo, let's say, and you're doing natural care too and three months
later, it's still 4.5 centimeters.
And then they're saying, well, it's stabilized, typically this is what they'd say, and
it's a bit of an aware of the cancer, isn't stabilized, now it's time to do surgery
and remove this tumor.
The question is, is there any way to remove the tumor somehow, dissipate the tumor without
doing surgery?
Well, you're always trying to do those things, you're using the right frequencies to get
your immune system to kill it and to destroy it.
The problem is sometimes your body walls it off, the fibrous sheath so that you can't
get at it at all, that's very common with lung cancers and it's common in breast cancers
as well, it's common in brain cancers too.
So there's nothing you can do but surgical removal if you do want to have it removed.
And it's time that that's when it can be appropriate, if the surgeon has confidence that they
can go in there and basically get it all or most of it without having to dissect the tumor
itself and break it up and cause possible spread by doing that.
That's the time to do surgery.
So I don't have any success stories of I can't think of anything off my head of any anecdotal
stories of the person, you know, what he was pressed to do surgery and then did some
natural approach in the tumor shrunk.
We've had plenty of patients where the tumor did shrink and was gone and wasn't able to
be filed afterwards.
But that wasn't how the question started is that it gets to the point where it's no longer
a definition of cancer and it's because it's not growing, it's staying at that same size
for experience of months, therefore it's not continuing to rapidly replicate.
Is there a way to diminish the size?
Well, in truth, if the patient is our patient, we're doing everything we possibly can from
a natural perspective to diminish the size.
We're not trying to just stop it from growing, we're trying to get rid of this thing.
But if the final solution is that it just stops growing, all like it was is, hey, if that's
good enough, it's not blocking the lumen of your colon or if it's not, you know, blocking
or pressing on, you know, your bile duct or an artery or something, you're better sometimes
just letting, you know, sleeping giants lie.
But if there is a need for removal, it's blocking a percentage of the lumen of the colon or
it's putting pressure on an artery and the person's having 18 spells or something, then
surgery is probably the best option.